ryan welcome to las vegas now
good morning rocky good to be here again
good to see you so we're talking first
time home buyers so for example if
that's me you know what what are the
tips that you have from clark county
credit union to start preparing for this
major life milestone i'd say that's
right three points you want to keep in
mind one talk to a loan officer
a lot of people wait and they kind of
hesitated second guess talking to a loan
officer will kind of put you on track
they'll let you know what you need to do
even if you're not ready to buy
something now they can get you on the
path three months six months a year from
now whatever your timeline might look
like
number two
be aware of debt to income ratio this is
kind of a hard one it's a little
complicated but uh one of the biggest
things we see people run into is they
try and buy a house but they've got a
big car payment so that car payment can
be a big hurdle especially for
first-time home buyers luckily at clark
county credit union we can refinance
your auto loan if you have a high
payment or anything like that so that
can help but if you're in the market for
a car
and a house get the house first you know
and then three priorities okay exactly
get the house first right number three
start saving you know um if you haven't
already started contributing to a 401k
that's a big one you know you could
start saving that way with pre-tax
dollars and you get a match from your
employer so that's big and you can use
those funds to go towards your down
payment and your closing costs and then
don't forget that even once you buy a
house and pay all your closing costs
you'll have expenses like moving
expenses maybe uh painting or flooring
or you know just a new furniture
anything
so with that said you know how do you
determine
how much to start saving in advance
that is kind of where the loan officer
comes into play right so they'll
determine exactly how much you need some
of the different programs be it you know
conventional fha va any of that they all
have different requirements for down
payment and closing costs and monthly
payments but usually you're looking at
about three to five percent for a down
payment if you're looking at a condo
depending on the the community you might
need 10 if you're looking at an
investment property that could be 20
down here at clark county credit union
we just came out with a program that
allows for two percent down
two percent down okay so that's music to
people's ears right
yeah that's big
it's big in this market you know um how
do you qualify for that though
so so basically you have to be a uh it
has to be a primary residence if you're
looking to buy you've got to have a 620
fico score you have to have two months
of payment reserves
and uh and there are income requirements
depending on the number of people in
your household and things of that nature
so if you had more questions about it
feel free to contact the credit union at
702-228-2228
and we can go over everything you might
need to get qualified for that that
program is really a great opportunity it
has a below market interest rate and it
also has below market mortgage insurance
which makes it easier for people to
qualify and it's got a high cost high
interest rate market that we're in right
now
thank you again to clark county credit
union for sponsoring this segment you
can call them at
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org for more information and
don't forget that you can contact the
credit union today to learn more about
their mortgage down payment assistance
programs